Sunshine was a relatively complex app
in terms of integration points because
a successful outcome relied on
both user and server input.
We did a great job dealing with
certain aspects of that wide range.
The first thing we did was using a
SyncAdapter to load data from the server
in the background,
we never see partially loaded
data because of this choice.
It keeps our data relatively efficient,
and it makes efficient use of battery.
Even if we have not opened
the app in a while,
the data is being updated
behind the scenes.
The second thing we did well
was caching our data locally.
This is why being offline is only
critical when first starting
the application or
changing the location.
Caching keeps our data still accessible
when the user's not connected
to the Internet.
Without this, our weather app
would display a blank screen
any time your device went
through a patch without service.
And that, would be terrible.